- [Shopper] Absolutely ridiculous.
- [Reporter] A months-long shortage
of baby formula in the US,
caused by a mix of supply
chain issues and a recall,
is putting desperate parents on edge
as they scramble to find
ways to feed their babies.
- For those babies who
are not being breastfed
or otherwise getting human milk,
formula is the only alternative,
and it provides all of their nutrition.
- [Reporter] So what can parents do now?
And more importantly,
what should they avoid?
(mellow music)
- Definitely do not water it
down or make your own formula.
These are dangerous
and there's simply no
safe way to do those.
- [Reporter] Dr Steven Abrams,
a former Chair of the
Committee on Nutrition
at the American Academy
of Pediatrics says that,
similar to breast milk,
baby formula contains
protein and nutrients
that are crucial to a child's
development and growth,
such as calcium,
phosphorus, iron, and zinc.
- [Dr Abrams] When you make your own,
you can't get the nutrients right
and it's hard to do it in
a way that's sterile enough
to make sure that you're
not risking infection.
When you dilute the formula,
you're simply giving the baby extra water
that they don't need,
and they're filling up their
tummy with water and not food.
It's what they need to grow.
(mellow music)
It's okay to switch baby formulas,
unless your baby has
special medical needs.
- [Reporter] Experts say it's safe
for most healthy babies to switch
to any FDA-approved
formula parents can find
from reputable distributors.
The American Academy of Pediatrics warns
against buying formulas on auction sites
that are not monitored
or regulated by the FDA.
- [Dr Abrams] Babies who
have specialized problems,
especially those with severe allergies,
families need to talk
to their pediatrician
before they switch.
(mellow music)
- [Reporter] As major
retailers like CVS, Walgreens,
Kroger and Target impose
purchase limits on baby formula
to avoid panic buying
and hoarding products,
experts recommend checking
smaller local stores
and pharmacies.
- I've seen it, for example,
in stores that only sell kosher food,
because they make the
specialized kosher formula.
Sometimes you'll find it in smaller stores
that you might not expect to find it in.
(mellow music)
- [Reporter] At least 31 milk
banks in the US and Canada
are collecting donations
from lactating women
and distributing pasteurized milk.
These members of
the Human Milk Banking
Association of North America
are currently helping families
facing difficulties due
to the formula shortage.
- [Dr Abrams] The problem is that most
of that milk goes for premature babies,
so there isn't a whole lot
left for the general use,
but as long as the milk is
pasteurized, it's quite safe.
(mellow music)
- [Reporter] Although the CDC says parents
who want to give their
children cow's milk should wait
until after the infant's first birthday,
Dr Abrams says this can
be a last resort option
for babies older than six
months, in case of an emergency.
- For short periods of time,
a week, two weeks of time,
you can use whole cow milk
if your baby's not allergic.
- [Reporter] Dr Abrams
says parents should talk
to their pediatricians about
getting an iron supplement
for babies who are on cow's milk,
because whole cow milk is too low in iron
for the nutritional needs.
The shortage, which stems
from pandemic-related supply issues,
worsened after Abbott Laboratories,
a major formula manufacturer,
voluntarily recalled some
products and closed a plant.
On May 16, the company announced
that it had reached a deal
with the FDA for the reopening
of their formula plant,
but a date has not yet been confirmed.
On May 18, President Biden invoked
the Defense Production Act,
to help manufacturers increase
production of baby formula.
The administration also
launched a new program
that would use commercial aircrafts
to pick up overseas formula
that meets US standards.
- I'm hopeful that the
government allowing imports
and increased production
will begin to see a turnaround
over the next couple weeks,
but I think we're still gonna
be need to be very careful.
I don't expect to see full resolution
until, really, multiple months from now,
and families need to be aware of that.